veamos qué sucede cuando multiplicamos
de 10 en 10 y veamos si observemos si
algún tipo de patrón emerge a la vista
entonces tenemos aquí vamos a iniciar
con 11 x 10 esto a que es igual 1 por 10
es igual a 10 eso ya eso ya lo sabías
pero si multiplicamos por otro 10
entonces tendríamos 1 por 10 por 10 a
que será igual eso por 10 entonces 1 por
10 es igual a 10 y 10 por 10 eso a que
está que es igual eso es igual a 100
cierto esto es igual a 100 ahora ok
perfecto veamos qué pasa si
multiplicamos por otro 10 entonces
tenemos uno por 10 por 10 y esto
multiplicado por 10 a que será igual
esto ya sabemos que que uno por 10 por
10 es igual a 100 y 100 multiplicado por
diez
eso es literalmente 10 tienes 100 dieces
entonces esto es igual a 1000 así que
cuál es el patrón aquí veamos ok
esta está muy divertido aquí multiplique
yo di es una vez y obtuve un cero acá yo
multiplique diez dos veces y obtuve dos
ceros pero acá yo multiplique diez tres
veces y obtuve tres ceros en la
respuesta entonces cuál es el patrón
veamos vamos a hacerlo otra vez aunque
parezca un patrón sencillo entonces
vamos a multiplicar ahora por 4 10 es
iniciamos con 1 y multiplicamos por 10
ese es nuestro primer 10 ahora por el
segundo 10 y ahora por el tercer 10 y
finalmente por el cuarto 10 entonces a
que será igual esto bueno pues esto será
igual a lo que ya tenemos arriba como
respuesta mil multiplicado por 10
entonces mil multiplicado por 10 lo cual
es igual a 10.000 esto es igual a 10.000
iniciamos con 1 y lo multiplicamos por
10 4 veces como puedes ver y obtuvimos
10.000 entonces uno seguido de uno dos
tres cuatro ceros
así que dejándolo en claro iniciamos con
uno y lo multiplicamos por 10 1
234 veces entonces el resultado es uno
seguido de uno dos tres cuatro ceros y
entonces ves el patrón aquí aunque tal
vez pienses o espera es doloroso tener
que hacer todo esto en escribir todo
esto es como doloroso entonces no existe
alguna manera de alguna operación que lo
facilite recuerdas aquellos tiempos en
los que sumaba repetidamente si por
ejemplo tenías 10 + 10 10 10
sabías que es ahora igual a 4 por día es
cierto entonces debe pasar lo mismo para
la multiplicación si yo tengo 1 x 10 x
10 x 10 x 10 entonces esto es lo mismo
que tomar 4 dieces y multiplicarlos
porque bueno el 1 no no cambia el
resultado entonces 10 x 10 x 10 x 10
debe existir algún atajo para esto debes
pensar en eso entonces si estás en lo
correcto
existe un atajo y se llama exponente si
tienes tu 4 10 es y los sumas eso es lo
mismo a 4 por 10 si tomas 4
si lo multiplicas eso es lo mismo esto
es igual a dar a 10 a la cuarta potencia
así que viese la cuarta potencia
literalmente significa tomar cuatro
dieces y multiplicarlos o podríamos
visualizarlo de esa otra manera tomas un
1 y lo multiplicas por 10 4 veces
entonces esto también es igual a 10 a la
cuarta potencia y el de acá de arriba
tenemos 1 y 10 3 veces multiplicándose
entonces esto es igual a 10 a la tercera
potencia y este de aquí es 10 a la
segunda potencia o 10 al cuadrado
mientras que el primero tenemos un 1 que
multiplica a 10 entonces solo tenemos un
10 así que esto es 10 a la primera
potencia 10 a la 1 y solamente bueno
solo para que te familiarices con la
terminología aquí el 10 se le llama base
así que 10 es la base y este 4 es el
exponente entonces dada la anotación
vamos a practicar un poco pensemos en
que aquí es igual por ejemplo que te
parece
ok hace 10 a la sexta potencia a que es
igual eso y ponle pausa el vídeo intenta
hacerlo hay dos maneras puedes verlo
como un 6 10 es entonces tienes esto
igual a 10 10 10 10 10 y 10 y los
multiplicas entonces multiplicas eso o
podrías verlo también como inicias con
un 1 y a ese 1 lo multiplicas por 10 6
veces entonces de cualquier manera que
vas a obtener veamos si tú multiplicas 1
x 10 6 veces terminarás con 1 seguido de
6 ceros y ahí ya vimos qué es ese patrón
tendrás 1 seguido de 1 2 3 4 5 6 ceros y
eso es igual a un millón entonces 10 a
la sexta potencia es igual a 1 que
multiplica
16 veces o thomas 6 dieces y los
multiplicas obtienes 1 seguido de seis
ceros entonces es decir un millón y ya
está fácil cierto nos vemos pronto